[موسيقى]
تتمثل إحدى قيمنا الأساسية في أن الشركة
لا تأخذ نفسك على محمل الجد في
نهاية اليوم الذي نبيع فيه الملابس الداخلية
، أنا أريان من بريان لالا وأنا الرئيس
التنفيذي لألبسي الداخلية وأنا  شركة الملابس الداخلية
للرجال والنساء هي أكثر
من مجرد ملابس داخلية ، نحن نجعل الناس يشعرون
بالرضا والراحة
لأنفسهم ونقوم بتحديث درجك بملابس
داخلية جديدة رائعة كل شهر لا
يعرف الناس عدد الأزواج التي يجب أن
تمتلكها وليس شيئًا لك
نفكر باستمرار في ذلك إذا قمنا
بوضعه في وضع الطيار الآلي من أجلك
وجعلناه ممتعًا وكل شهر تحصل على
زوج جديد ، فسيتم
تحديث درجك باستمرار وستحصل دائمًا
على تجربة رائعة قبل هذا
من أي وقت مضى للاشتراك في الملابس الداخلية
ولكن لماذا لا
[موسيقى]